Fox News host Bill O'Reilly faces
questions this morning after new details
emerge about harassment allegations the
New York Times investigation found that
five women received a total of thirteen
million dollars in payouts they were
made by Bill O'Reilly or Fox News parent
company that's 21st Century Fox now in
exchange the women agreed not to pursue
litigation or speak about their
accusations of sexual harassment and
inappropriate behavior in a statement
the company says quote 21st Century Fox
takes matters of workplace behavior very
seriously and while he denies the merits
of these claims mr. O'Reilly has
resolved those he regards as his
personal responsibility CBS News reached
out to the women name to the New York
Times report they declined to comment or
did not respond New York Times
correspondent Jody canter is a CBS News
contributor
good morning Jody good morning lots to
discuss here first two of these
settlements came after Roger Ailes was
dismissed by 21st century and after Fox
said in a statement the behavior that
disrespects women or contributes to an
uncomfortable work environment will not
be tolerated that's pretty significant
that is the real significance of this
story because last summer they were so
clear about the fact that this kind of
behavior was not going to be accepted at
the company and yet what my colleagues
uncovered is that they're still settling
these claims
so if Roger Ailes had to go under these
circumstances why does Bill O'Reilly get
to stay right now that question is
really for Fox not for us but I'll give
you two theories one is that Bill
O'Reilly is the key on-air personality
at Fox News he is the public face of
that channel in so many ways another is
that remember last summer Fox was still
negotiating to keep megyn kelly it's
biggest female star at the company and
here's where we she's no longer there
she's no longer there but at the time
they really wanted her to stay and as we
know she was very troubled by these
kinds of harassment claims said that she
had been subject to them herself
actually so you see part of the power
that having a prominent woman at the
company is is that the same reason that
the company is supporting O'Reilly well
certainly it's in their interest to keep
their talent on the air he has a huge
following Bill O'Reilly has released a
statement he says
just like the other prominent and
controversial people I am vulnerable to
lawsuits from individuals who want me to
pay them to avoid negative publicity so
what do you make of that response and
doesn't it open the door now for people
to say well he's gonna pay I might come
up with a claim well I would keep in
mind that there's a pattern here this is
not one woman who's come forward this is
now several so the idea that he's the
real victim here and that these women
are targeting him to get him to pay up I
think there are some questions about
that talk about that pattern as the New
York Times reports Oh Riley would create
a bond with these women he would offer
them advice promised to help them
professionally and then pursue sexual
relationships with them so they were
worried that if they rebuffed him it
would hurt their career that is what
Michael Schmidt and Emily Steele
reported and remembered that the context
here is that Roger Ailes was running Fox
News so it was very hard for a woman to
go to management and complain because it
turns out that management was subject to
exactly the same kinds of complaints
good well I should say Axios is also put
on a list today of the 15 women at least
15 women who have accused Bill O'Reilly
and Roger Ailes of sexual harassment
just this is systemic I mean this is
this is a huge problem it's the top
cable news company it's the person who
ran that company it is the biggest star
at that company and if you look at the
amount of money that has now been paid
out in response to these allegations
it's a massive amount of money okay Oh
Riley in 21st Century Fox also say this
that no one has ever used an anonymous
company hotline to report concerns why
do you think that this is an important
point that they're making
well I question whether a sexual
harassment claim can ever really be
anonymous on a company hot exactly
because if I bring a sexual harassment
claim in order to investigate it or
pursue it you have to go to the person
who supposedly did it and say hey an
employee is raising these concerns about
you now the probability is that that
person is going to Know Who I am
was it was a car Larry question raised
as to whether Fox accurately reported
this in terms of
their own income statements and in terms
of their balance sheet that is the
subject of a federal investigation right
now we don't know what it's turning up
but as we know when investigators start
rifling around in your business a lot
tends to come out and so I think the
question is what the findings will be
with regards to those payments but also
what else will they find out about
operation sister because the relevance
is that they were paying them as though
it were a salary as opposed to a second
right that's what's under investigation
is the story they told me giving
somebody immunity maybe yes one of
former Fox News executive does have
immunity do you think the story is over
now that the settlement has been
announced that's what we don't know
these allegations have just kept coming
since last summer all right Thank You
Jody Canton thank you